[Applause]
how are you and would you like a green
beer yes please okay is this is this
your water that is yours this is kind of
a liquid Zone we've got Waters beers
I've got coffee I've got uppers and
downers it's like that's very La
um so you know Dame Helen of course
y'all did a movie together so we did a
series of vision in blue and I saw him
last well it would be interesting
you know you don't always have the
scenes with the actors you don't always
actually interact right sometimes we
haven't seen the other on the rooftop oh
yes yeah that's right yes
um oh I remember that and yeah so we did
have a scene together but sometimes you
don't you know I've worked with I mean
I've you know been in movies with people
I've never met sure I know I find that
crazy I started this job interview
people are like wait what
that's just crazy too just an ignorant
person watching the film thinking y'all
are barbecuing after set you know like I
don't know so but there was quite a
little barbecuing after after work
thanks to Zach on Shazam wasn't it it
was really a family feeling wasn't it it
was and this was a second one so uh a
lot of us knew each other already and
he's a very natural leader so he had I
mean he just had the best house too so
yeah yeah I had everyone had everyone
over yeah Zachary yeah yeah okay yeah
okay yeah yeah the best digs he had the
pool yeah I want to go to his place in
Texas he has like a whole lot I heard
yeah yeah it's like for musicians and
stuff so I'm into that all right so you
were a big fan of Comic-Con right like
growing up like you I was a big fan of
comics and I am from San Diego where
comic V Comic-Con is held in that set
I'd never been and I wasn't yeah do you
know when it started I actually don't
know is it is it around from the 70s and
got big or has it did it just come in
the this millennial
yeah but I just he's obsessed my
actually both of them are superheroes
but he's very into Spider-Man so I took
him and got him a Spider-Man comic book
and he thought it was the coolest thing
ever yeah because it looks like just
magical you know it's different than the
normal books they have to read in school
so yes no they're very fun and it's a
combo of
they're very visual but then the stories
can be interesting and yeah I remember
I've you know very impressionable and
have specific ones that meant a lot to
me who are your favorites
they used to do
um it was a mar it was Marvel it was
like a Marvel Christmas special and
every year they would come this is
probably like 19 early 90s and they
would come out with um like an anthology
at Christmas time and like a 10-page
story like 10 10 page stories involving
Wolverine or Spider-Man or whatever
Christmas themed stories and I don't
know I really love it that's cool I
didn't know that I just always loved it
cool but
um wait we should do a green beer toast
because um you were gawker's sexiest man
alive in 20 22. let's touch look eye
contact there you go see to toast it up
I'm just saying that's a it's a fun
title how long did you have it I think
it was only about two weeks because they
were they truly because they received
for a good year no no I I um they
rescinded it a couple weeks later and
gave it to I forget his name but like I
think it was like it was they literally
rescinded it let me finish it okay yes
but because the youngest it was like the
youngest member of Congress ever was
elected to to Congress I think it's a I
forget his name but I'm pretty sure it's
a man um but anyways they give it to him
and that's worthy that's more worthy
than me
once something's been given you don't
take it back I think it was It was kind
of Joe I don't know how official the
title really is
[Music]
[Applause]